my favorite death was the saris with the
the gold that's gotta be high on the
list of top scream deaths of all time
rodrick assails they had seen I thought
that call sequence was you know one of
the most hardhat and powerful moments of
the entire show have to be the one with
the rap and the barbecue
George's twisting like no one saw that
coming everyone I was like I love
owner's death that just being stabbed in
the belly was just so pallet at the
table just from behind and just death
that just the anguish I was quite sad
when viscera side an episode a like
right at the beginning just because he
was a really good body I think on crowns
incredible golden crown for a king so he
says then pause milky gold on his face
until he dies absolutely epic murder
poor Alfie had to like chop off that
man's head didn't he and then it
wouldn't come off and he had to kick off
like a football I remember him coming
back to the hotel that night there are
five spice blokes has the kick his head
off on it and he kind of strangely
enjoyed it I really liked moderate
Cassell's death because I killed him as
good the death of the horse
it was absolutely horrifying it worse
summer than Shawn going it was so so
unfair the way they captured meds
passing was so perfectly pitched between
brutally truthful but also some sort of
suspense but just knowing that no you're
gonna see his head on a spike a minute I
mean I did I ate still gets me they look
hot still get personal point of view la
means was horrible yeah
my sword as well like that's kind of I
mean jewelry getting it in the eye was
pretty spectacular
Viserys is I think that's you know
that's one of the most creative they're
the scenes and television yesterday it's
just incredible I remember him saying to
me when he was about filming he was he
was kind of doing some research about so
what exactly would happen to me if
molten gold was poured on my head how
would I die he was so excited about
shooting out I was so excited and he
again he nails that scene but the
moments before his death you just you
sort of almost going with him it's very
hard to go beyond the red wedding at the
moment seeing those people go I think
that's still gotta be the toughest might
be the Catelyn Stark went was very yeah
it's hot what I thought the the general
polishing off of all OH
while those enemies was pretty classy
still we just had a a great week of
total carnage and I enjoyed every minute
of it I'm afraid to say